le président roumain klaus iohannis ce
nous avons la traduction au niveau 35
antique nous sommes à vos côtés pour
défendre nos valeurs communes et les
bases des fondements de ce décor de cet
ordre mondial c'est pour ça que vous
combattez richert l'ukrainien
une
agression non provoquées délibéré à
justifier elle doit être arrêté j'étais
énormément touché par
par ce que j'ai pu voir à rpi donc les
conséquences de ce drame qui a causé
tant de
tragédies humaines et les destructions
les ruines qu'est la laisser derrière
nous apportons notre soutien à toutes
les enquêtes qui sont en cours pour
punir les responsables de ces crimes
avec le président hélène ce qu'il nous
avons envisagé les voies concrètes pour
surmonter cette menace existentielle
nous allons poursuivre cette recherche
commune donc des meilleures voies pour
aider l'ukraine à faire face à cette
invasion russe une autre échanges
d'aujourd'hui
donc été focalisé sur cette nécessité de
restaurer la paix de reconstruire le
cren et de lui donner
un avenir qu'elle mérite la roumanie
était d'aider dès les premières heures
aux côtés de l'ukraine
et depuis ils essaient de faire tout son
possible pour l'aider et pour aider ces
populations
[Musique]
les privations qu'ils subissent à cause
de cette agression
plus d'un million d'ukrainiens sont
actuellement accueillis en roumanie
essentiellement des femmes des enfants
nous avons mis à leur disposition
tous nos infrastructures
éducatives et autres
plus de deux cent cinquante mille
enfants sont accueillis dans les écoles
roumaine plus de 3000 emplois mise à
disposition des déplacés craignant toute
la société civile roumaine se mobiliser
de manière jamais vue donc pour venir en
aide aux amis ukrainiens et les
ukrainiens peuvent continuer à compter
sur le soutien du gouvernement et du
peuple ou même temps qu'il le faudra
la roumanie a mis à disposition ce rap
internationale dans la ville de suceava
bas qui fait le dispatching donc d aide
humanitaire à destination de l'ukraine
plus de quarante convoi ont été si déjà
je traitais nous constatons un autre
instrument de chantage que la russie
provoquent que lequel russie utilise ces
les céréales donc et ceux ci risquent
d'avoir des conséquences planétaires
nous avons
échangé effectivement sur la manière de
faire face à cette menace
donc pour subvenir
à cela nous avons effectivement mis en
place le transit pour les céréales et
craignent un passant par la roumanie
nous essayons de faire tout notre
possible pour mettra à profit le port de
constanta et d'autres port sur la mer
noire roumanie
le port de constance à issy assurer le
transit de plus d'un million de tonnes
venant de l'ukraine et nous ouvrons ce
moment à l'ouverture de nouveaux points
de passage sur la frontière roumano
ukrainienne
et nous nous
essayons de remettre en exploitation un
tronçon de chemin de fer qui va
permettre d'accroître le transit de
marchandises par cette voix venant de
l'est traîne
non sont ouverts une collation
internationale
pour mettre en place un corridor bleues
c'est à dire
le transport passant par la mer noire
donc nous avons envisagé la perspective
de cette reconstruction de l'ukraine à
la sortie de cette guerre
nous avons souligné le rôle majeur qui
revient dans ce travail l'union
européenne nous devons mettre en place
un outillage indispensable pour
concrétiser toutes ces bonnes intentions
nous vivons un point marquant un
tournant dans l'histoire du continent
européenne ce temps majeur dans
l'histoire de l'ukraine
nous ce nous interpelle et sollicite de
notre part toute la responsabilité des
décisions courageuses
donc
[Musique]
les actes de candidature pour l'adhésion
à levon être vont être envisagées celle
de l'écrin celle de la moldavie la
géorgie
donc et 7
cette perspective s'inscrit bien dans
cette nécessité commune qu'elle un autre
pour pour garantir la sécurité et la
stabilité du continent européen
nos partenaires
attend de notre part
des décisions qui vont encore accroître
en force et notre capacité à faire
ensemble face à tous les défis qui se
posent devant nous sur notre continent
monsieur zelensky chers amis nous sommes
réunis tous ensemble et si conscient du
fait que qu'il est de notre devoir
d'agir d'agir ensemble et c'est la
responsabilité historique et qui est
reposé sur nous ne pas rater cette
chance d'aider nos amis prégnant
d'ouvrir cette nouvelle à venir